okay so we got the revelation and yeah
that's pretty much the focus this
episode I mean not like a ton happens
but at the same time it's a pretty big
deal what you'll find out or at least a
good start to what I'm guessing is gonna
be the villain looks like it's going to
be our villain this is the episode where
Korra um you know she's training with
her two or two new teammates now and
she's also training continuing to train
with her master and she saw it has that
method of going through the spinny doors
whatever that is she has that down
better I guess they got new ones because
I'm ready to burn the last ones um so
she's getting the training down but
they're short on money uh they're
finding it really tough to survive and
get cash so sort of this old gang friend
comes to one of the team members and
offers them a chance to you know just
not do anything illegal just you know a
job you know very forties New York guys
stuff so um so he gets captured though
by these bad guys and Cora and mokou go
and they try to find out what happens to
him they find that he's brought to this
place where the villain this masked
villain I starting this big revolution
against benders they see Bender's as
really bad and they they want to be the
great equalizers because they're given
these advantages and they're allowed to
push people around and call all the
shots and that's not fair so they want
to find out a way to stop that and this
guy has found a way to take bending away
which is never been done before except
by Aang I think I don't know if anyone
else said but as far as I know Aang's
only one that's done it so this is like
an impossible feat uh so they get the
guy out to get the the teammate out but
they now know there's this great big
threat and this is like what start
officer like the small protests and just
this these people bitching and yelling
is now like a legit dangerous movement
you know that could turn into like this
big uprising so uh yeah this is
definitely different than avatar which
again I like I like that they're going
this different direction um the one
thing that I do
miss I'm fine with all the changes I do
find the one thing I miss that I think
they're gonna keep going with is that
you can't stuck in the city what I liked
about avatar is they're always trying to
get to someplace or they arrive at a
place and they look around the place
here it's mainly the city and you can
see different parts of the city um but
it's still the city you sort of see one
part of it you get kind of a general
idea unless they're going to do like
sorta New York really is where they have
sort of these different parts of the
city and each sort have their different
attitude and different design and stuff
but so far it kind of looks the same it
looks impressed so the animations like
holy but I do serve miss that that
essence of traveling from place to place
um you know where originally it was
seeing these places for the first time
and introduced you to this world and
then whatever next week you'd be
introduced to a new world uh here you
could do that again because you could go
these places again and see how they've
evolved see how they've changed and they
do that sometimes like I said they show
certain characters and their offspring
and how they've grown up and such but
that is the one thing I do kind of miss
um everything else I'm still okay with
because I like I like the idea of this
story I sort of said before it's sort of
like what they deal with children I'm
doing where it's what's after happily
ever happier what's after the Messiah
the chosen one because the stories
always stop and say yes and the only
Tapley ever after that doesn't
happen you know what are the problems
they're gonna come after then I like
stories that do that and that is what
this is doing and this seems like
something that would happen where you
sort of have you know and you see this
happen our culture all the time where
you come from something that's really
bad you know whatever a war or a
depression or something that's really
terrible and then when things start even
out there's still these problems there
right they're just new problems and the
problems that from before you wouldn't
even think of her if anyone was even to
try if anyone was even to say the
Bender's are bad or threatening our way
back then you know back in the Avatar
days
nobody be like what are you talking
about they're the only ones that can
like save us right now and but now that
they have been saved and time has moved
on there's sort of this this different
problem as risen which is are they given
too much of an advantage or too much
power um and some have abused the power
I mean held that the Fire Nation and
Avatar of course abuse the power so it's
it's an argument that you can see where
they're coming from which I like now of
course they're going to an extreme
they're saying all benders are like this
all blah blah blah and that's an extreme
but that often happens when people are
very angry at stuff or get pushed around
or whatever when others are using
extreme that just spreads more extremes
and that's not the best thing to do uh
you know again that's why I like the
idea of the Avatar coming in and
bringing balance here this is a
different kind of balance that's trying
to be brought here so I like that and I
like that it's being done with a person
who is already kind of aggressive and
trying to learn more the sort of calm
inner silence and be comfortable with
herself and the philosophies and so on
so forth you know cuz she she can very
easily fall into sort of one of these
criminals even when she came in it's
like you know these people were doing
bad and she just fights them you know
and kicks their ass I mean doesn't
question anything she just beats him up
and then even when the police comes she
doesn't try to settle it she runs away
and tries to beat up the police and so I
this is a good story for her to fall
into this is sort of a good predicament
and I hope they really have fun with
like the challenges they can really
throw at her um so but in terms of
challenges like this episode seem very
much like just serve a set up like okay
here's our villain who looks like a cool
villain it's given a good backstory it
looks like um wouldn't be cool they take
the mask off and it's like there's
nothing wrong with them um I'm wondering
there guy go that route that'd be cool
but I digress
uh you got the this villain that that's
set up and now you serve no the threat
and you sort of know what the focus is
gonna be and yeah I like it you know I
brother would say he's seen the show all
the way through he hasn't grown anything
from me but he
saying that we're avatar was very much
sort of like the Lord of the Rings the
neverending story you know where it's
the travelling movie this is sort of
like the Dark Knight this is the city
this is the one location and how it
works and you know actually spending
time it's you know maybe there is
something to that you know you traveled
all these different places in Avatar and
it's great but you're there and then you
leave you know why not actually serve
get the inner workings of it and see how
it comes about and what the different
personalities are and the problems with
just one place and really dive into it
which they did a good chunk of the time
in Avatar but here to actually devote a
series to it could be interesting um I I
wish and maybe I'm just wishing the
different parts of the city would look
more different you start go to one part
of the city you go to another it's a oh
that could be that part of it like these
five different areas of the city been to
can also to be interchanged I mean they
look very similar and compared to avatar
again where you would go from one land
to another it's like wow totally
different looking place and you can tell
exactly where you are because of how
well design these places are um but here
it's sort of like Oh were we in this
part of the city or that part of the
city they kind of look alike so I know
that's the one thing like to see more of
its like the initial design of the city
is great but when you're gonna look at
it for a very very long time I want to
see they're gonna maybe try a few
different variations with it or
different areas because you know I been
to New York and while New York is very
massive and Men much of it cancer look
the same uh there's definitely different
areas that are designed you know very
specifically and have their own
identities so I like to see if they
maybe would try that and I'm wondering
they're gonna have a little bit more fun
with that but uh no just it's still good
still having fun with it and curious to
see where it's gonna go and just
enjoying this new direction so that's
about it now see you at Episode four